on retrouve à Ottawa Chrysler ministre
et ministre des Finances du Canada
bonsoir madame Freeland
bonsoir madame merci d'être avec nous on
est bien heureux de vous recevoir
dites-nous pourquoi il est important
aujourd'hui à l'aube d'une possible
récession de nous annoncer parce que
c'est la première fois que les libéraux
le font une cible d'équilibre budgétaire
avec un surplus budgétaire dans 5 ans
nous avons comme vous savez très bien
présenter du scénario le scénario de
base ce n'est pas mon scénario c'est le
scénario basé sur les prédictions des
économistes du secteur privé selon cette
scénarios vous avez raison on aura une
surplus en 5 ans mais nous avons aussi
présenter une scénario plus pessimiste
parce que comme vous savez très très
bien il y a beaucoup d'incertitudes dans
l'économie mondiale et dans cette
scénario plus pessimiste on n'a pas une
surplus mais on a une position fiscale
forte
votre scénario de référence madame
freelen c'est pas le scénario pessimiste
vous ne prévoyez pas de récession
présentement
vous travaillez sur d'autres soutiens au
canadiens en vue du budget de 2023
pour dire la vérité c'est la question
pour moi personnellement même au niveau
émotionnel la question la plus difficile
parce que je comprends que la vie est
difficile pour beaucoup de gens je
comprends ça
c'est difficile pour moi de le savoir de
le voir et je sais que notre
gouvernement notre gouvernement c'est
une gouvernement qui est très
compétissante nous sommes une
gouvernement qui veut être là pour les
Canadiens et c'est pour cette raison que
nous avons des mesures oui ciblés ciblez
pour les gens qui en ont besoin comme
pour exemple
le TTS et les chèques du BTS
arriveront commençant demain
il y a pas de nouvelles mesures
importantes aujourd'hui annoncée pour
les Canadiens pour faire face à
l'inflation
non je ne suis pas d'accord
je finirai très vite en disant que pour
moi la chose importante c'est d'avoir
une approche qui est d'une côté
compétition d'autres côtés responsables
à cause de cette situation
d'incertitude mondiale mais en même
temps il y a quelques mesures aussi
ciblées qui aideront les Canadiens qui
en ont besoin on va aider les étudiantes
cette importante et les jeunes
aujourd'hui vraiment centré touché par
la situation économique et on va aider
les travailleurs les pires payer les
moins nantis avec la location canadienne
pour les travailleurs c'est aussi une
aide ciblée mais
4,2 millions de travailleurs canadiens
vont recevoir cette aide c'est beaucoup
et ce sont les gens qui en ont le plus
besoin pourquoi ne rien annoncer de
nouveau aujourd'hui pour les années des
choses ont été annoncées mais pour les
personnes de 65 ans et plus plusieurs
espérait quelque chose dans votre énoncé
économique
l'atps l'échec de tps arriveront aussi
dans les comptes bancaires des aînés
et je suis d'accord avec vous c'est une
aide importante et je veux aussi
souligner que on a été on a ajouté par
10%
à les
allocations les paiements ou les plus
vieux alors les gens qui ont le plus
besoin la sécurité de la vieillesse pour
les 75 ans et plus mais pas des 65 ans
et plus il y en a beaucoup qui vous
réclament une réforme de l'assurance
emploi en supposant qu'il y a une
récession qui s'en vient le chômage va
monter est-ce que vous est-ce que on ne
devrait pas élargir l'accès à
l'assurance emploi est-ce que vous
travaillez là-dessus
ma collègue la ministre car la croattro
travail très très fort elle fait du
travail acharné sur ça notre
gouvernement est d'accord que une
réforme est nécessaire mais je dois dire
aussi que cette système le système de
l'assurance-emploi au Canada est très
importante et très très compliqué et on
doit être très certaine que les
changements sont les bons changements
une chose importante parce que vous
parlez des travailleurs canadiens notre
approche responsable fait du côté fiscal
ce n'est pas seulement parce que on veut
être responsable on prend cette approche
aujourd'hui dans des conditions
d'incertitude globale parce que on veut
être là pour les Canadiens si les
conditions changent
une manière
pire pour les Canadiens et je veux
rassurer les Canadiens que le fédéral a
les ressources pour être la pour les
Canadiens vous annoncerez dans le budget
de 2023 des mesures pour répondre aux
grands soutien du gouvernement du
jobiden à la production de batterie
électrique pourquoi c'est pas maintenant
dans le monde des affaires les
manufacturiers exportateurs du Canada et
du Québec disait aujourd'hui c'est
maintenant qu'on a besoin de cette
stratégie pour attirer des
investissements ici parce que les
États-Unis investissent massivement
on a déjà une stratégie verte
industrielle on a commencé avec notre
stratégie industrielle et la transition
verte en 2015 notre gouvernement est
très très ciblé sur ça et on a annoncé
en avril avec le budget plusieurs
d'autres programmes pour faire ça c'est
évident dans les annonces on n'attend
pas on a juste
vous attendez budget de 2023 madame
Freeland pour répondre au enfilation
rédaction acte de Joe Biden vous
l'écrivez là aujourd'hui non je ne suis
pas d'accord
on a mis en place beaucoup de mesures en
avril aujourd'hui on a mis en place des
autres mesures mesures concrètes l'appui
pour l'hydrogène la pluie pour les
indestissements dans la technologie
verste et on a aussi dit que d'ici la
fin de l'année la fin de croissance
canadienne qui aura 15 milliards de
dollars pour investir à côté du capital
privé sera là alors on a déjà fait
beaucoup mais vous avez raison en disant
que on a dit aussi que on va faire de
plus à l'année prochaine c'est dans
chaque budget je pense que aujourd'hui
la transition verte l'action climatique
c'est si important que dans chaque
énoncé économique
chaque piéger ce sera nécessaire de
mettre plus mesures plus d'argent là
mais je peux vous donner des exemples
concrets
est-ce que je peux ajouter une petite
exemple s'il vous plaît
est-ce que François Philippe fait des
annonces presque chaque jour utilisant
de l'argent qui était mise en place pour
la transition verte dans le budget on a
fait alors c'est une démonstration que
l'argent est là que on n'attend pas ok
on a compris
merci d'avoir été avec nous bonne soirée
à la prochaine
ok merci beaucoup et je m'excuse un peu
difficile pour moi d'exprimer en
français mais merci pour les questions
qui sont importants Merci à VOUS bonne
soirée ok bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI